all right chef/owner Dora thanks for
coming in as Craig we're here to talk
about startup school
so Jeff could you break down what's
happening this year with startup school
sure well startup school began a couple
of years ago with a course Sam taught
online called how to start a startup and
last year we evolved it into a course we
taught the Stanford called startup
school and we're continuing that this
year it's an open online course that is
a way for us to reach as many companies
as possible throughout the entire world
to help maximize really the amount of
innovation and the amount of value
created by startups everywhere in the
world
Anna Dora how it is the coursework
differing this year from any previous
version well it's there are a lot of
similarities so we that's a 10-week
course and you you can either audit the
course or you can actually be part of
the you can apply for it to be part of
the course and to be part of the course
you get obviously access to the
materials and lectures you're put into a
group you get an advisor who you will
meet once a week to you know go over the
obstacles that you're having but more
importantly to talk with other founders
as well who are in you know dealing with
similar challenges and then you also you
have access to community which will be a
forum in which you can talk to everybody
else who is taking startup school so
it's really great because at the end the
day what we want to do is reduce the
barriers to starting a startup and I
come from the middle of nowhere
personally and so you know it's near and
dear to me because I you know I didn't
learn about startups until very late
like I would consider like a late
bloomer compared to people who are from
here and so I think that what's
important is to give people out there
who are not in Silicon Valley access to
community access to mentorship and
access to really great knowledge to
build their startup mmm so the amazing
thing about startup school is it's not
just the content this is really unique
it is about the community
and the and the mentorship that every
single one of the founders in in this
advisor track where you can assign an
advisor and you meet with them on a
weekly basis
now it's also true that the content this
year is going to be different than the
content last year all of the content
from the last two years is available
online will remain available online and
is relevant and useful but it turns out
also that the content relevant to
starting a start-up is both broad and
deep there's a ton of things to cover so
we're going to cover everything a little
bit differently we're going to go over
similar areas of a start-up how to get
going what the mechanics are how to
think about product how to think about
growth how to think about fundraising
but we'll do them all and in in new and
different ways that I think will be
valuable additions to the set of content
that we've already actually made
available in a public library that you
can get at its startup school org slash
library hmm and the speakers for this
year is that Louis public yet well the
list is about to be public I think
simultaneously with the publication of
this podcast so we can't start to talk
about it one of my favorite speakers is
going to be a Dora and we're really
focusing on YC partners and YC founders
for this startup school so a number of
YC partners are going to be
participating I'm really excited to to
say that Paul Graham and Jessica
Livingston will be taking part in the
course and giving some of their wisdom
which is also broadly two founders
everywhere in the world but we're also
gonna have otherwise he partners Sam
Altman who's the president of Y
Combinator will be giving a talk Michael
Seibel the CEO of Y Combinator will be
giving a talk so we have an amazing
line-up of folks who are we're gonna be
out there talking ok cool
so we should just clarify all these
questions around the tracks right now I
think that's like isn't necessarily
clear for folks who have maybe
participated before
or just heard a little bit about it so
adora could you explain like the
different paths of going through startup
school yes so there are two paths one is
just you can audit the course in which
case you just get access to the live
stream and lectures and the notes or you
can be if you're especially if you're
full-time founders you can just apply
and be part of startup school officially
which means like I said before you get
access to mentorship mentor sorry
advisor is you get access to the forum
you acts you get exclusive deals like
with Amazon stripe Atlas exam and so
forth and and you also can qualify to
receive a $10,000 equity free grant from
us right if you complete the course and
we're gonna choose a hundred companies
that get that that get that grant based
on well the how they do during the
course and the information we're going
to get from the advisers and and the the
progress that company makes so we're
going to judge how promising that
company is those companies are yeah and
those companies could they apply at any
stage like who are the founders that you
guys are looking for I think the most
interesting are people who are
early-stage founders so they're either
either they have an idea and they're
ready to work on it full-time
or they are currently working idea and
anywhere from no users to you know any
number of users is fine I think we can
be helpful along those lines yeah I
think startup school is is it's fair to
say is certainly targeted at very
early-stage companies there's knowledge
in that and the knowledge base that that
we've built in the past in our
continuing to build with this year
startup school that are there's probably
useful to tech companies in later stages
as well but for the most part this is I
think adora put it well is about it was
about lowering the threshold for people
to get started okay really get your
startup going
gotcha do you guys recall so from last
year were there any success stories that
kind of stood out to you whoo so we had
38 companies who actually
got into our core YC program after going
through startup school and so they don't
they I think but for the most part most
of them did a lot of their iteration and
talking to users during startup school
and they learn a lot how to do that
which I should pause you and say that
that's a very high percentage of the
batch like 38 oh there's three to cross
across to bad team yes but still 10% yep
yeah and success stories um I mean I'm
very excited about a few of those
companies so one of them is actually I
worked very closely with in my group
it's connection I PE they actually went
through MOOC with a something in the
legal space which they're still in but
they iterate it towards their current
product during start-up school so I
think that's really exciting their
connection IP is there enabled patent
law firm so if you need any should just
add adora through in this term MOOC
which we often use internally to talk
about the course that stands from
massively open online course yeah and
it's sort of a most people know that
term but that this is how we think of
startup school it's it's it's it's a
MOOC it's for everyone so open to
everyone so no matter what if you apply
to be part of the the main course and
get an advisor and and for whatever
reason and we do have a limited number
of advisers so we can't take everyone
but you can still take the course
everyone who applies can can audit the
course can can go through all of the
lectures and see all the content and at
the end of the course as we said all of
the content is going to be available
online caches so so given the success of
last year's MOOC which Jeffie are
organizing why did you decide to do the
grants this year if it was already
working we want to maximize the amount
of innovation in the world and it's just
a hard fact that starting a start-up
takes cash so to be honest it's a bit of
an experiment right certainly it helps
to attract companies to come to startup
school we think the starb schools good
for them we drive no benefit unless they
apply to a comma
and get into Y Combinator except that we
think it makes the world a better place
to have more startups so it's good if
more do startups cool and we think that
the most promising startups that don't
get into Y Combinator but still have a
shot have a better shot if they have
some capital to work off of
so our fervent hope is that by giving
ten thousand dollars to these hundred
startups will have startups that might
otherwise die not die succeed and thrive
and become viable companies gotcha
okay and so just to clarify the deals
you mentioned earlier what are they
explicitly so people know ethics the
exclusive deals so we have cloud credits
from Amazon Web Services and digital
ocean and maybe some others and then
every company that comes through will be
able to incorporate and create a bank
account with through stripe Atlas there
may amazing company the work with Clerke
for incorporation yes and will have or
will have a bunch of others but those
are the highlights cool so applications
are open right now and they've been open
for a week they've been over for a week
or more when this podcast is yeah yeah
what's the packet it'll be two weeks and
I do want to really encourage people to
get their application in it turns out
this is a really popular thing and lots
of people are applying and we're already
thrilled by the response it's great we
have thousands and thousands of
companies already applying and when will
the course begin the course is going to
begin the week of August 27th it's going
to actually have a live in-person
component in Mountain View California at
the original YC offices on pioneer Road
we a minor way excuse me but but also
the obviously we can't take everyone
there since there will be many thousands
of people taking the MOOC so the the all
of the lectures and the slides will be
made online and made available online
shortly after each lecture
mm-hmm and who can attend in person how
does that work we're actually working
through that we think you know we think
the demand is gonna be super high and we
want to be as equitable as possible
it's sa really interesting correct the
the startup companies in circle are the
companies from around the world but it's
also true there's a there's a good
number who are in the Bay Area yeah so
we don't we don't expect or really even
recommend people travel if I'm gonna try
to come to the course because that
actually will probably detract from your
startup you should be focusing on
startup the startup itself and building
your company and talking to your users
and and and building your products not
traveling out to Mountain View right for
people who are local and who want to
come in will have some mechanism for
them to reserve a spot and come in and
and actually attend the lecture in
person and just to clarify or to add on
to that is the live is just you know an
option it's not a requirement for course
completion or to qualify for the $10,000
mm-hmm but there are requirements we I'm
sure doors about to say that but what we
to be eligible to to take part in in in
a presentation day at the end where you
can present your company in time
hopefully there'll be will be an
audience of investors and other and the
community to to to take a look at what
you've done what you've accomplished but
also to be eligible for the for the ten
thousand dollar grant you need to attend
nine out of ten of the weekly group
meetings with your advisor and you need
to consume at least nine out of ten of
the yes 18 out of 20 make sure that that
occur on any basis okay so the course
adora mentioned this the course it runs
from ten weeks starting on the week of
August 27th and it runs through the end
of October not coincidentally that is
right
in the application period going into the
interview period for our winter 2019
batch so we actually will help people
apply to YC will give you maybe not
insider information but accurate
information about how to think about
creating an application and having your
best shot at having your company
considered for membership and in that
there's a lecture dedicated to that
there's a it will actually be a lecture
dedicated to helping people do that look
it's hard to get into our core YC
program the admission rate is somewhere
between one and two percent so we think
we think that alone is a great reason to
come through startup school
the main reason startup school will help
you get into YC however is not because
we have a lecture dedicated you know
that the main reason it will help you
get into YC is because we sincerely
believe it'll make your startup better
right and you will have the forcing
function of working with a group over
ten weeks well that's part of it yeah it
turns out that the forcing function of
working it part of a group and having a
community over ten weeks makes your
startup better it makes you focus it
makes you achieve it makes you grow so
we um we expect those things to really
be relevant so the companies that are
applying so in addition to this section
on applying to I see what else is in the
curriculum like let's go from the
beginning of the first first course and
then just go from there yeah this is
hard because we have to do it from
memory and it's ten courses but it
follows an arc that I think will be
pretty familiar to folks we're going to
start off by talking about some of the
really basic ideas behind starting a
startup why you do it how you should
think about it I should even
mechanically go about doing what you
need to do some of these things every
part of doing a startup is hard but
sometimes just getting over those first
you know small steps is the key thing to
actually getting on the road to building
your startup then we'll spend a fair
amount of time talking about product
okay what is a start-up without what is
any company without a product ycs motto
it turns out is make something people
want so we'll spend a fair amount of
time talking about well what it really
means to make something people want to
find sort of the proverbial product
market fit and then we'll go on to to
talk about well so how do you think
about getting users and growing once you
start to have a product that's
reasonable and then you know we'll spend
a fair amount of time on that and we'll
spend a fair amount of time on on things
like how to think about running your
company and hiring people and and then
we'll transition to to talking about
fundraising how that works how you think
about cap tables and and then and as we
get towards the middle part we'll talk
about applying to YC which is sort of
right in that sort of in a lot of people
think about YC as a as a mechanism for
fundraising although I tend to argue
it's much less about fundraising that's
a piece of it and way more about making
your startup more likely to succeed and
then we'll have some cool stuff at the
end that'll have that little that will
revolve around both thinking big
thinking big about the future thinking
about that the key things that make
startups succeed and fail and and even
psychological and emotional things
because as anyone who's done a start-up
a door has been through this and as an
intensive way as you possible I started
as an emotional roller coaster it's
really complicated and hard and and
coming out the other end as good a
person enter at the beginning is really
uh is really a hard challenge mm-hmm
what about those sessions with advisors
you know around YC we talk about office
hours and group office hours and
advisers and all that stuff I think it's
not always clear what actually happens
during those meetings and then to be
clear like these are online sessions
and so they're happening weekly correct
what's actually happening during it
because you know following the
coursework is interesting which is like
the traditional model if you're working
with a TA for example but in reality
they're more talking about what product
growth during the whole course I would
say the coursework is a little bit more
on the theory side and abstract in an
attempt to teach everybody yeah
something relevant to what they're doing
and then in group office hours it comes
down to more tactical things and very
specific things and so we're going to
try to group you with fellow founders
who are working on similar type similar
industries and obviously hopefully
similar locations so you don't have to
get up at wacky times for this but most
importantly I think the general
structure is you come in and you
describe you know what has happened in
briefly what has happened in the past
week have you met your goal if not what
was the main obstacle and how can the
group help you and so the mentor
actually is not there to I would say
tell you exactly what to do they're
there to facilitate the conversation
facilitate a conversation because I
think in most cases a lot of the things
a lot of the problems you run into other
founders have run into in just very
different forms and so it is other
founders who will probably help you the
most and so that's what we're that's
what we're hoping for
mmm the important aspect of the hours
even though they're done in group is
that they're actually individual
attention for each company each company
gets to spend time talking about what
they're working on what progress they're
making what problems there or barriers
are running into and and it's a sore
points out it's the post the advisor and
the other founders within that context
who can help and and you know take part
in the community of startups trying to
be successful it's actually the coolest
part I just actually it's worthwhile
saying just a word on the advisors who I
I think more than anything make this
work and it's really a test
^ the YC network that YC founders are so
interested and like I don't know how how
how open I should be about this but I'll
just say we don't pay these folks to do
this they volunteer their time yeah for
a free course to spend time with
companies that they've never heard of
before and to help them be successful
and these folks are amazing they're
there they're in many are most cases
working on their own startup at the same
time but they dedicate their time
they're very valuable time to help these
strangers make their startup work it's
it's really more than anything else what
I think makes startups cool powerful
yeah and and and interesting beyond sort
of any online course you can follow and
and you know and any book you can read
about how to start a startup this is way
more real way more effective and I would
say way more substantive to the future
success of your startup yeah well I
think it really helps you stay locked
into the course because that's been you
know churn has been a huge problem with
many MOOCs right I think it's not
uncommon to have less than 20% of the
class percentages and and last year 56%
finished and you know our goal is higher
this year and and I think a door pointed
out you only get a chance at the $10,000
if you finish so we expect that is one
of the reasons we hook this in place at
the tail end of the course because we
think that is going to incent people to
finish because we think it's good for
them to write your start then as a
better shot right so before we move on I
think we should also shout out the
people at YC that we're working on this
with you guys because it's not just you
to know who else was working on it with
you well Steven Pham Stevens the main I
mean you know Steven does more than
anyone he's amazing he worked on it with
Sam last year yeah and I think he worked
on startup school too didn't know how to
start a start-up too as well but he's
amazing he
hoots the advisors he puts a little
everything together he makes he makes it
work when it works so he's he's sort of
he's the guy yeah and then we have two
engineers who are working with us as
well Ramon and Kyle
otherwise he software team get in
because there's a whole software side to
this obviously yeah we built like for
the most part we build this ourselves we
use our own software and we manage this
with our own stuff we actually it's
actually non-trivial to put together
software that makes it that that makes
it scalable to work with you know
thousands of thousands of companies yeah
obviously we we have smaller scale but
even within my c1 we have hundreds of
companies were working with we need
software to help us scale at this level
we needed all the more so and so the
they've done it they did an awesome job
last year we're improving it again this
year we get lots of feedback from the
companies and from the advisors and how
to make the software even better so yeah
the Catalan Ramon have been amazing yeah
right on so on a personal side for you
guys when you were startup founders
which of these classes do you think
would have been most valuable to you
like what was the thing you knew least
about where you could have learned the
most all of it when starting off oh my
gosh like I mean I'm from a different
generation and when I when I when I
would when I wanted to start her up
there was nothing available yeah the the
there's there's we said this before but
it's worth repeating the contents
awesome like just if you if you go to
that that that URL I mentioned for the
library and you start going through
there it's incredible there there's also
a lot of start-up content elsewhere on
the web and some of it not all of it but
slow it's pretty good too I happen to
believe that the startup content that's
been put together both at wise so it's a
mix of startup school content and other
content that's been generated and on
some external content that we think is
actually particularly good at and we we
point to but that coupled with the
community and the mentorship that
startup school represents like that
alone yeah is worth the price
a mission which is free but but that
alone is is amazing and and
game-changing as far as I'm concerned
mm-hmm you haven't answered the question
my question is that's the community and
the focus and having that from me
like again the content is great is
fantastic but but you have nobody around
you yeah yeah I think I answered the
question you're right you didn't
question my bad aura same yeah I think
in general when you think about YC it's
it's all about the network and you know
it's it's a community of high-quality
entrepreneurs yeah um and you can't get
that anywhere else and so we want to do
this for start-up school as well it's
like you can live anywhere and plug into
a network you don't you know like this
will be the highest quality place you
can be at to talk with people about your
startup all right thanks guys thanks for
your time
hey thanks a lot Craig goes fun yes
you